[موسيقى]
لسنوات سعه الشركات والدول الاوروبيه
لتوفير بدائل للانظمه الامريكيه في مجال
صناعه الاسلحه جزء من الامر كان ضمان
استقلاليه القرار الاوروبي الجزء الاخر هو
زياده الايرادات من سوق الانفاق الدفاعي
الذي يصل الان الى تريليونات الدولارات
شركه ايرباص هي واحده من الشركات التي
حققت نجاحا كبيرا الان في اوروبا وكذلك
على مستوى العالم من قلب العاصمه
الاسبانيه مدريد نقدم لكم هذه الحلقه
الخاصه حيث نسلط الضوء على اثنين من اهم
منتجات شركه في مجال الطائرات طائرات
النقل وطائرات التزود بالوقود في الجو
اهلا بكم في عسكريتانيا
الكثير من المراحل تمر بها طائره عملاقه
مثل طائره اي 330 ام ار تي تي هذه هي
واحده من هذه المراحل دعونا نتعرف بشكل
اكبر على المراحل التي تتم بها تصنيع
طائره اي 330 ام ار تي تي من السيد توماس
وهو رئيس انتاج طائرات اي 330 ام ار تي تي
اولا مصر توماس اهلا بك معنا في
عسكريتانيا في البدايه دعنا نتعرف بشكل
مبسط على المراحل التي تمر بها طائره اي
330 ام ار تي تي سواء في التصنيع وكذلك
فيما يتعلق بالمصنع هل لديكم وحدات انتاج
جديده وما هي كذلك ابرز هذه الوحدات
بشكل اساسي هذا ليس خط التجميع النهائي بل
هو مركز تحويله نحن نستلم الطائره خضراء
قادمه من تولوز ونبدا بعدها عمليه تحويل
الاعداد الصناعي هو كالتالي لدينا ثلاث
حظائر نقوم في المحطه الاولى بالتعديلات
الهيكليه وتركيب القطع الكبير والالواح ثم
النظام وبعد ذلك تركيب الاسلاك من اجل
اعداد الطائره وفي هذه المرحله يجب ان
تكون الطائره معلقه بسبب الشد الكبير على
الهيكله اما المرحله الثانيه فتشمل قلب
عمليه التحويل كما نرى هنا في هذه المحطه
وما نقوم به في هذه المرحله هو تركيب نظام
والاسلاك والقطاع والجهاز الاساسي لقدرات
التزود بالوقود جوانا وكذلك محطه المشغل
حيث يتمكن مشغل اعاده التعبئه بالوقود جوا
من توجيه الخرطوم جوا لتعب الوقود بنجاح
وبعد ذلك ننتقل الى الاختبار الارضي
الداخلي والخارجي قبل ان نذهب الى خط
الطيران واجراء اختبارات الطيران ثم تسليم
الطائرات الى العميل مصر توماس بالمهمه
الواحده كم طائره تستطيع طائره ام ار تي
تي ان تزودها بالوقود خلال المهمه الواحده
وكذلك ما هي نوعيه هذه الطائرات وهل لديها
القدره على التكيف مع كافه انواع الطائرات
والمقاتلات
جدا لانها تعتمد على نوع المهمه التي يرغب
العميل بادائها المهمه النموذجيه قد تشمل
اربع طائرات في مهمه اعاده التعبئه
بالوقود الى جانب طائره ام ار تي تي ومره
اخرى الامر يعتمد بشكل كبير على الوقود
داخل الطائره لدينا سعه
110 اطنان من الوقود كما تعتمد على
المسافه التي يجب ان تقطعها من اجل تزويد
الوقود كان هناك حديث انه حدث مشكلات فيما
يت تزويد مقاتلات او طرازات محدده من
مقاتلات اف 15 حدث هذا في استراليا وكذلك
في الولايات المتحده كيف تعاملت مع هذا
الامر وبالتالي هل نحن الان نستطيع ان
نقول بان طائره ام ار تي تي ليس لديها
مشكله فيما يتعلق بتزويد اي طائره في الجو
بالوقود
الريفي
في الحقيقه فانا اعاده تعبئه تعمل مع
تشكيله مختلفه من الطائرات وبشكل اساسي مع
جميع الطائرات سواء المقاتله او طائرات
النقل وكل عملياتنا مرخصه وعندما قمنا
بترخيص التعبئه الاوتوماتيكيه مع 16
وطائرات الاكبر فان الخطوه التاليه ستشمل
اف 15 ايضا
فيما يتعلق بالمستقبل الان هناك شركات
تعمل على انتاج مسيرات تعمل على تزويد
الطائرات بالوقود في الجو فيما يتعلقتكم
هنا في التصنيع داخل ايرباص ما هي هذه
الخطه وكذلك ما هو شكل المستقبل بالنسبه
نحن نسعى لتطوير قدراتنا بشكل مستمر
ومؤخرا تمكنا من ترخيص اي 3 ار وتزويدها
بقدرات التزويد الاوتوماتيكي بالوقود
جوانه والخطوه التاليه التي نفكر فيها بعد
ذلك هي اعاده تعبئه الذاتيه التي تمكن
طائره المزوده للوقود بالتحكم بالطائره
المستقبله
كما تبعثم الطائره من الداخل ليس بها
اختلافات كبيره عن الطائره التقليديه سوى
فقط الاجنحه التي تسمح لها بالقيام بمهمه
التزود بالوقود في الجو وحينما دائما نسمع
كلمه التزود بالوقود في الجو يتبادر الى
ذهننا التساؤل الاكبر وهو كيف تستطيع
طائره ان تقوم بتزويد طائره اخرى بالوقود
في الجو هذا ما سيجيبنا عليه المهندس
خورخي وهو مهندس اختبارات طائره اي 330 ام
ار تي تي لتزود بالوقود في الجو مهندس
خوخي اولا اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتا كيف
تستطيع طائره ام ار تي تي تزويد طائره
اخرى بالوقود في الجو
من اجل اعاده تزويد طائره بالوقود فيجب ان
يتوفر نظامان الاول هو نظام الخرطوم
والمرصاد حيث نرسل الخرطوم من الجناح
وترتبط به الطائره المستلمه عن طريق
المرساد ثم يتم نقل الوقود النظام الثاني
يسمى بومه الذي يقوم المشغل فيها باستخدام
عصا تحكم لايصال ذراع من الطائره المزوده
للوقود الى خزان الطائره المستلمه هذان
هما النظامان المعياريان في كل القوات
الجويه في العالم
بالتاكيد انت حلقت بهذه الطائره من خلال
تحليقك السابق بهذه الطائره ما هي النقطه
الاصعب في عمليه تزويد طائره اخرى بالوقود
في الجو
عمليه التزود بالوقود جوا عمليه معقده
لانها تتطلب اقتراب الطائرتين من بعضهما
وهذه الحركه تحدث في المهام العسكريه ولا
نشهدها بين الطائرات المدنيه ولهذا علينا
تدريب الاشخاص المعتدين على التحليق عن
قرب من الطائرات الاخرى والمشغل يجب ان
يكون متمرسا في توجيه العمليه وقادرا على
التواصل مع الطائره الاخرى لربط المرساد
ولهذا السبب تقوم ايرباص بتطوير نظام
اوتوماتيكي لاعاده التزود بالوقود اسمه اي
3 ار يستخدم الكاميرات لتحديد موقع
الطائره وتحريك اوتوماتيكيا
[موسيقى]
الان ننتقل بكم من مدريد الى اشبيليه حيث
مقر تجميع وتصنيع طائرات اي 400 هذه
الطائره التي تتعدد استخداماتها تستخدمها
بعض الدول في النقل الاستراتيجي او حتى
كذلك في مهام استراتيجيه او تكتيكيه كما
تستخدمها دول اخرى كذلك في عمليات التزود
بالوقود في الجو خلال هذه الرحله كذلك
سنتعرف على مراحل تصنيع هذه الطائره التي
تتشارك في تصنيعها وتجميعها عده دول
اوروبيه
[موسيقى]
الان وبعدما تابعتم وشاهدتم طائره ايه 400
ام جاء الدوره للحديث عن مراحل تصنيع هذه
الطائره الضخمه وكذلك المده الزمنيه التي
تستغرقها حول هذا الموضوع سنتعرف على كل
هذه المعلومات من السيده رافائيل بوتيو
رئيس الصيانه والتحديث لطائره اي 400 ام
بشركه
اهلا بك معنا في عسكري تاليا يعني دعنا
نتعرف على مراحل التصنيع وكذلك المده
الزمنيه التي تحتاجها طائره ايفور ام حتى
تكون جاهزه للتحليق
شكرا
الى منشاه تركيب طائره اي 400 ام يشرفنا
وجودكم هنا معنا هذا هو المكان الذي تبنى
فيه طائرته اي 400 ام وتختبر وتطير لاول
مره قبل تسليمها الى العميل ومن اجل تحقيق
ذلك فنحن نستلم المكونات من مناطق عديده
من اوروبا الاجنحه مثلا من بريطانيا
والمثبت الراسي من المانيا ومكونات اخرى
من فرنسا وتركيا ودول اوروبيه اخرى
فيما يتعلق بطائرات النقل الان هناك
الكثير من الشركات التي تقدم طائرات نقل
ما الذي يوجد لدى طائره اي 400 تستطيع ان
تقول انه لا يوجد في طائرات النقل الاخرى
رامز
هي اكثر طائره متعدده لاستخدامات متوفره
حاليا وهي تستجيب لتشكيله واسعه من
احتياجات القرن الحادي والعشرين للقوات
الجويه العالميه والمنظمات الاخرى
وبامكانها تنفيذ ما لا يقل عن ثلاثه انواع
من الواجبات الهجوميه والمهمات
الاستراتيجيه مباشره الى موقع العمليات
كما بامكانها ان تعمل كخزانه فهي الحل
المثالي لانزال الحمولات من
المتدنيه وانزال الجنود من الارتفاعات
العاليه والمنخفضه مثلا 40 الف قدمي
للقوات الخاصه وبالاضافه الى ذلك وكما
تعرفون فان طائره اي 4 ام حلقت بارتفاعات
منخفضه خلال ظروف مناخيه محوريه لانها كما
نعرف صممت لتكون منخفضه وصعبه الكشف عنها
فيما يتعلق ببدايات طائره ان كانت هناك
شكاوى فيما يتعلق بالمحرك وعدم قدره
المحرك على تحمل الوزن الكبير الذي تتحمله
هذه الطائره وكذلك امور اخرى تتعلق
بالهيكل اولا هل هناك اي شكاوي الان فيما
تتعلق بطائره ايفور هند ريدم
ى
ان تقول بكل سعاده ان كل التحديات التي
واجهناها والتي قادتنا الى هذه المرحله من
الزمن تستحق جميع الجهود التي بذلناها نرى
طائره اي 4 بكل فخر وهي تعمل كقوه من اجل
الخير في الحرب ضد كوفيد 19 واجلاء
المدنيين الافغان من كابول او لايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه في باكستان هذه مجرد
امثله عن خدمات طائره اي 400 عام
لمجتمعاتنا
لكل طائره معايير ومواصفات قياسيه خاصه
يجب ان تتحقق قبل ان يتم السماح لها
بالتحليق حول المعايير والمواصفات
القياسيه المطلوبه من طائره اي 400 سنتعرف
عليها الان مع المهندس
سايمون ني كاسترو وهو مدير برامج اختبار
طائره اي 400 ام التي تنتجها شركه اولا
مهندس اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتانيا فيما
يتعلق بالمواصفات والمعايير المطلوبه حتى
يتم السماح لطائره ايفور ما هي هذه
المعايير حتى تكون الطائره جاهزه للتحليق
بشكل امن
مرحبا بكم الى مركز اختبارات التحليق
المدنيه متطلبات المعايير التي يجب ان
تستوفيها طائرات اي 400 ام عاليه ودقيقه
حيث ان الهدف الاساسي من تصميم الطائره هو
للايفاء بمعايير الاعتماد المدنيه وتلك
المعايير توازي معايير الطائرات التجاريه
التي تنتجها ايرباص ولكن علينا ايضا ان
نشمل القدرات العسكريه الهجوميه التي يجب
ان تستوفى بالمواصفات العسكريه الخاصه
بالمعايير العسكريه وقد اتفقنا منذ بدايه
البرنامج على ان العميله هو الذي يحدد
المعايير التي تطبق على الطائره وهذه
المعايير تطبق على تصميم الطائره وادائها
وقدرتها على عكس الطائرات متعدده المحركات
لا تدور محركات طائره اي 400 ام في نفس
الاتجاه اولا ما هو الهدف من هذا الامر
وكذلك كيف يتعامل الطيارين الذين يحلقون
بهذه الطائره مع هذه المساله
تصميم دوران المحركات باتجاهات مختلفه هو
تصميم جديد ويقدم فوائد كبيره خاصه فيما
يتعلق بالاداء الهجومي للطائره الفائدتان
الاساسيه هما اولا الكفاءه الديناميكيه
الهوائيه من خلال تحسين التدفق المتناظر
فوق جناح الطائره ما يمكننا من تحسين قدره
الجناح على الحمل وعلاوه على ذلك هناك
فوائد خاصه بزياده السيطره على الطائره
تحت الظروف غير الطبيعيه وفوائد لهيكل
الطائره فيما يخص تاثير عزم الدوران على
هيكل الجناح واجراء مبادلات التصميم
للتعويض عنها انتم في قسم الاختبارات
الهندسيه هل تنتهي علاقتكم بالطائره بعد
ان يتم تسليمها للعملاء ام ان هناك دور
اخر تقومون به بعد تسليم الطائره
بعد تسليم الطائره يقوم العميل باخذ
الطائره الى قاعده تشغيل الطائره الرئيسيه
ومن ناحيه اختبار التحليق فهذه اخر محطه
لتعاملنا مع الطائره الا ان تعاوننا يبقى
وثيقا مع العميل طوال برنامج اختبار
التحليق مؤخرا اجرينا حمله اختبار تحليق
مع بريطانيا حيث زودناهم بالكثير من
المعدات وحلقنا معهم كطاقم مختلط كجزء من
استعراض تاهيلي وشمل ذلك التزود بالوقود
جوا والتحليق التلقائي واليدوي بارتفاعات
منخفضه والايصال الجوي
[موسيقى]
الان بعد هذه الجوله التي تعرفتم فيها على
اثنين من اهم منتجات شركه ايرباص جاء
الدوري للحديث عن التوجه الاستراتيجي
للشركه في المستقبل خاصه في ظل التنافس
العالمي الشديد بين الشركات المصنعه سواء
لطائرات النقل او حتى لطائرات التزود
للوقود في الجو للحديث حول هذا الموضوع
معنا السيد خسيلويس مدير التسويق بشركه
اولا مصر اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتانيا دعنا
نبدا بالحديث عن طائره اي 330 ام ار تي تي
وكذلك
يعني ما هو الاستراتيجيه وما هو الهدف من
ان تقوم شركه ايرباسك بدمج يعني مجال
النقل وكذلك مجال التزود بالوقود في الجو
في الطريقتين رغم اختلاف مهام يعني طبيعه
المهام سواء في النقل او حتى في التزود
بالوقود في الجو
ان كان هناك من ميزه علينا ذكرها في
الطائره الحديثه فهي التناغم فالمنتجان
الجديدان يستعرضان مزايا التنوع في حلول
عاليه الاداء ان تحدثنا عن طائره ام ار تي
تي فهي طائره تزويد بالوقود الجويه وكل
الوقود الذي تنقله محمول على جناح الطائره
ما يترك الطبق السفلي كاملا للشحن والعلوي
لنقل المسافرين ما يعني ان كل رحله قادره
على حمل الوقود والشحن ونقل المسافرين وهو
الامر الاساسي الذي يميز هذه الطائره
والطائره الثانيه اي 4 ام ايضا مصممه على
نفس النحو بحيث تنفذ ثلاث مهام في ان واحد
معا بوسعها ان تسافر لمسافات قصيره وتهبط
على مدارج قصيره المدى وبوسعها السفر
لمسافات طويله وبسرعه عاليه جدا كما
بوسعها التزود بالوقود جوا ويمكنها ان
تحمل خزاني وقود على الجناحين اضافه الى
خزان اخر مركزي وهاتان الطائرتان مثال حي
على التنوع والمرونه اللذين تتمتع بهما
هاتان الطائرتان
من المعروف الان بان هناك تنافس كبير بين
الشركات المصنعه سواء لطائرات النقل او
حتى لطائرات التزود بالوقود في الجو اين
موقع شركه ايرباص من هذا التنافس وكذلك
على الجانب الاخر ما الذي تستطيع ان تقدمه
لا تستطيع الشركات الاخرى ان تقدمه
لعملائها
المساله بسيطه جدا في هذا النموذج من
الطائرات المنافسه في مجال التزود بالوقود
جوا ونقل المسافرين والشحن فالتنافسيه
تكمن في سعه الطائره للوقود والشحن
والركاب فطائره ام ار تي تي قاد قادره على
حمل 111 طن من الوقود وهو رقم يتجاوز
بكثير سعه الطائرات المنافسه 45 طن من
الامتعه وهو رقم اعلى بكثير من منافسين
وحمولتنا من الركاب هي اعلى ايضا اذ تصل
الى ثلاثمائه مسافر وهو يتجاوز قدره
المنافسين الامر ذاته ينطبق على طائره اي
4 ام فهي لديها قدرات فائقه ونحن نفكر في
جمع هذه القدرات التقنيه والاستراتيجيه في
مكان واحد اي جميع المهام السابقه اضافه
الى تنفيذ مهام لمسافات ابعد وتحمل 20
وتقطع اكثر من 30 الف ميل جوي وهو امر لا
تستطيع فعله اي طائره اخرى ناهيك عن انها
تنفذ هذه المهام بسرعه اكبر وعلى ارتفاع
اعلى لدينا كثير من المواصفات الخاصه التي
تضع هذه الطائرات في مرتبه عاليه بين
نظيرتها مصر الدول الان في الشرق الاوسط
تغيرت وباتت لا تسعى فقط الحصول على يعني
انظمه دفاعيه ولكن كذلك تريد ان يكون لها
حصه في مجال انتاج هذه الصناعات الدفاعيه
والعسكريه وبالتالي تبحث عن شركات تشاركها
سواء التكنولوجيا او المعرفه الى اي مدى
شركه ايرباص مستعده لتتشارك في المعرفه
والتكنولوجيا مع دول في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط
هذه المشروعات الضخمه على غرار ام ار تي
تي هي مشروعات تنطوي على تكنولوجيا عاليه
وتستخدم تقنيات متقدمه من مزود
التكنولوجيا لذلك فان هذه المشروعات
يعمل فرصا كبيره للتعاون والتطوير
والانتاج وعندما نفكر بهذه الاصول الضخمه
التي ستبقى بالاجواء على مدى 30 الى 40
سنه سنجد ان هناك فرصا كبيره في الصيانه
والتشغيل لهذه الاصول ما يمكن ان تكون
فرصا جيده للتعاون مع القطاعات المحليه
مسار الخسيلوي مدير التسويق بشركه شكرا
جزيلا على هذه التوضيحات كما تابعتم في
هذه الحلقه سلطنا الضوء على واحده من
طائرات النقل المهمه والتي اثبتت فعاليه
وجود بالفعل في اوروبا وفي العديد من دول
العالم وكذلك طائره ايف وهي الطائره التي
تقدمها شركه
كواحده من ابرز طائرات النقل الان على
مستوى العالم حلقه عسكريه لهذا الاسبوع قد
انتهت الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه
والمزيد من الصفقات في امان الله
[موسيقى]